gobble [__] gobble mad flavor
here I'm one of your favorite holidays
oh [__] we're going deep into the murky
waters just how you [__]
greetings on this beautiful
[__] Thanksgiving Day you
thought I was gonna let you down that
[__] Uncle Joe would never let you
down I know you're sitting around with
your beloved ones your family members by
this point they're about to drive you
[__] crazy
that's what uncle Joey tunes in again
from the bottom of my heart and from the
church from my wife and from mercy and
Lee and all the [__] in my
world happy Thanksgiving to you
[__] you understand me bust out
that reefer do it like the [__]
Indians and the pilgrims did it you
follow me
I got a tremendous day I got some
classic I got some [__] with no [__]
names just scribble on it we're about to
go deep you got to podcast you got
George Perez and you got [__] be real
to work with and I said the church is
with you I'm always with you
[__] even when you don't think
I'm that I'm [__] they understand me
tip-top Magoo looking good coconut water
MCT oil from on it you know I'm on it
and on top of that I went to jujitsu
today I got up early and [__] wrote
and now I'm spending time with my family
but Joey what do I give a [__] about
your itinerary let's kill this [__] a
goat that's exactly what I was thinking
here we got some [__] I don't even
know a list does it matter when I go to
the store they just give me this [__]
they give to [__] mental patients
that's it that's the way they want this
[__] they get the [__] mental
patients you follow me and that's it and
that's that I have some weed you give it
to a German they start hugging Jews and
apologize that's the type of weed we get
here
oh [__] just when you thought it was
safe and don't forget as always I got my
trusty little tushy cushy just to get
the party started I had a couple stars
earlier you know you when you eat
Thanksgiving you don't want to
disappoint you want to [__] up some of
these table you follow me when I came
back from jujitsu I just did a little
light little protein shake and now I'm
about ready to bust but just remember
Thanksgiving is a time to [__] [__]
with your family and realize how lucky
we are that we love each other as far as
you and I concern you know me how I roll
dog we'll family if you're my fan go
[__] yourself and want a fan I'm a
family a fan we're [__] family if you
don't understand that then you don't
understand what the church or what's
happening now what the [__] we're trying
to put together is about
mmm just like that motherfucker's no
[__] around it's like a thirsty hook
that's how I do it you ever bump into a
thirsty hooker
she'll drink piss come and [__] blood
they don't give a [__] but anyway my
point is it's about us this year the
next year this will arrests of 2017 and
2018 it's gonna be the year the church
it's your [__] lucky year you've been
banging your head off [__] for ten
[__] ten months what am I gonna do
with my life you got the answer you
understand me everybody i tones I this I
[__] [__] you got the [__] answer
but Joey let's go some more reefer
that's what I say have I told you this
is the best part of my day when I get
together with the church family and we
get down with no delay will rain on your
parade and rock your not when it comes
to rock give it all we got to be MCS we
got what it takes
let's a pop is pop and the break is
break you know saying I'm over here
giving it to you [__] full effect
[__] and that's it and that's
that I just want to take a little time
to tell you how didn't forget about you
remember always to the end I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
us the rest of them just suck our dick
you follow me when you see uncle Joey
what you see is what you get there's no
persona
there's nobody trying to be [__]
smart there's nobody trying to be cute I
don't give a [__] what anybody thinks
it's my [__] world the same way it's
your [__] world don't let
nobody [__] with I don't give a [__] if
it's a pilgrim an Indian on Apocalypto I
don't give a [__] what it is well you
know why we got to smoke another boat
just to make sure all the bases are
covered let's try out this new [__]
classic I haven't dried these out yet
does it happen at the time I went over
to the weeds don't see the weed stores
open here on [__] Thanksgiving Day
especially the Russians they don't give
a [__] they don't take days off only
Gentiles take the day
we're gonna meet over at bridges house
and drink wine first suck my dick go to
work for five hours [__]
and then at five ye you jump up and down
you do whatever the [__] you want to do
and that's it and that's that don't
forget people you want to see a good
[__] show December 3rd we will walk
the Joey Diaz the no vote either
downtown San Diego
I haven't seen you all year so this is
your chance for twenty bucks you get to
see uncle [__] Joey and we will walk
again at the observatory on the 4th and
Santa Ana I see you [__] on the
fifth again we will walk at my little
girl singing the [__] guitar that's
how we do it country meets [__]
comedy we're kicking down on [__]
doors we're not [__] around so get
online get those [__] tickets we're
gonna get down we're gonna be hitting
people with banjos and everything and
beside that you know I love you
[__] from the bottom of my
heart because without you I got nothing
that's what I'm thankful for
I'm not thankful for the road worth of
the [__] I'm thankful for you guys
that we got a family to [__] some
weird [__] connection that's the most
important thing to me from Bablu Lingus
to Bobbie sharing to [__] John Wolfe
to [__] Lord Rosen Kerr to ghazini I
mean the list goes on it my man Berg
even [__] crazy Armenian I got family
out there we are family and that's it
that's that man Australia I love you
filthy [__] savages are T ha T ha T
whatever the [__] you say you're [__]
savages I love you don't forget you see
Frank Barker you kissed his [__] ring
on his finger you have to and you never
assume we [__] go in there deep
assuming it's for [__] cuz you
assuming you assume you make an ass of
you and me we don't assume we go in
there deep like [__] understand
me
people gotta get me fired up I just
wanna come out here and give you a
simple [__] Thanksgiving a little
[__] take today and you gotta get me
all wound up like a [__] animal here
but besides that you guys know what I
know I'm the real deal Holyfield gotcha
I love your [__] when you come
out to my shows it breaks my heart
because you don't want ten years ago I
was robbing [__] persons who the [__]
are you kidding but you know what we did
this together so my heart goes out to
you [__] you're the real deal
and for once in your life you're where
[__] shirt to a [__] football game
and they lose one on the way you gotta
walk home with that [__] shirt on you
put my shirt on [__] I'll never
let you down I ain't taking my picture I
ain't doing nothing if anything it's
because we [__] took the [__]
down out of respect for the church oh
you could thank him I might the not be
annoyed with a Kewanee Chi and the rest
is the rest [__] I'll see you
guys during the week you know I never
let you down
you know I always pop up and with
[__] times you know I'm very generous
a qua like that
so I love you
and a toaster next Thanksgiving we're
doing this all over again when you bad
[__] and all of us will be
laughing because we'll be doing this
with somebody hanging off our [__]
dick
follow me [__] Kevin Spacey and [__] Roy
Moore - it's all about you [__]
happy Thanksgiving to you and your
families or you take it on and I'm
myself oh yeah they caught on some
together wire I love your [__]
don't take [__] from nobody and Charles
Manson's dead now feel so good myself
[__] it